a lull in fighting has made way for
potential dialogue the ethiopian
government is pardoning a number of
high-profile political prisoners
including members of the rebel tigre
people's liberation front
the government has been fighting the
tplf for more than a year amid ethnic
and tribal tension
prime minister abi ahmed's government
says the pardon's purpose is to pave the
way for a lasting solution to ethiopia's
problems in a peaceful non-violent way
especially with the aim of making the
all-inclusive national dialogue a
success
it was not immediately clear how many of
those granted amnesty have been freed
the war in the north has claimed the
lives of thousands of people and left
hundreds of thousands more facing famine
conditions in tigre which is under what
the united nations says is a de facto
blockade u.n secretary general antonio
gutierrez welcomes the news of the
pardon on twitter saying i will remain
actively engaged in assisting ethiopia
to bring an end to the fighting and to
restore peace and stability
the pardons coincide with orthodox
christmas a day widely celebrated by
christians in ethiopia
it also overlaps with a visit by u.s
envoy jeffrey feltman who was pushing
for talks the conflict has threatened to
tear apart africa's second most populous
state and to stabilize the horn of
africa region
but can the nobel peace prize winning
prime minister negotiate a solution in
his country divided by war
leah harding al jazeera